well at the beginning of the game i saw
malcolm butler um he was pretty intense
he was staying at harbaugh
and he was yelling and cussing at him so
you knew it was going to be an intense
game and if you're the tennessee titans
you knew that you had to win this
football game and they came out with a
a level of physicality um early in the
game
they struggled a little bit ryan
tannehill threw an interception but he
bounced back
and didn't really let it affect him the
rest of the game but
man when i look at aj brown aj brown had
a couple drops
he comes back in the fourth quarter and
makes some key physical runs
catches and and really he was the
difference maker in the fourth quarter
i want to hit aj brown when i hit corey
davis let's hear first though from both
head coaches this was rabel harbaugh
on what occurred some of the sound that
happened right before the game
oh we'll wait on the sound we'll get to
the sound here in a second not quite
ready yet okay so let's hit aj brown
the big play that stood out for me is
right there at the end of the game when
he catches the ball he has about three
defenders just circling him in every
single direction
seemed like one was going to tackle him
seemed like two was going to tackle him
none of them do
they don't even end up getting him on
the ground period he carries all three
into the end zone to go get that final
touchdown of the day
what stood out when you watch the wide
receivers of the tennessee titans to you
rodney
just the resiliency i mean you look at
you know when you have some drops as a
wide receiver
you start to lose your confidence and aj
brown never
he never lost his confidence i mean like
i said in the fourth quarter
for a guy with that type of size speed
and just the ability that he has with
the ball in his hands
those guys did not want to tackle him
because he's a big guy
six to 220 pounds he's fast he's strong
he's very intimidating that's what i saw
and what's so cool about vrable style is
he's not afraid to get in there and mix
it up like throughout the course of the
practice week even if you ever watch a
titan's practice he's out there like
hitting getting involved in drills with
the guys specifically when you watch his
style the way x's and o's schematically
the way he goes about it any
similarities between
he and belichick well obviously
he's very smart and he's extremely
patient
and really when you think about both
those guys i look at them and i think
they're teachers
because even when i played with vrabel
you know we would be in a meeting room
and we would have conversations
amongst the defensive players and you
would think that
we were coaches the type of
conversations that we we um
would have and we always knew that mike
vrabel was
probably the smartest guy on the
defensive side of the ball and we always
knew that he was destined to be a head
coach we thought it was going to be ohio
state
it ended up being houston for a while
but then um tennessee and houston as an
assistant in tennessee as a head coach
but i'm just so proud of him and you're
right we had a conversation
off the off on the air and we don't give
rabel enough credit i mean he was
phenomenal last year and he's doing well
this year even without a pass rush
defensively so as promised we want to
circle the wagons real quick come back
for this sound this is on the pre-game
mix-up like we said brave well not
afraid to do things like that
here are harbaugh and coach vrabel about
what might have occurred before the game
what was going on with the titans
players and their before and then
after the game uh after the game there
wasn't an issue i mean coach very blank
was down there celebrating in the end
zone then he came back around and
shook hands before the game it's
irrelevant i went to celebrate with uh
with derek and team to congratulate him
and then i ran back and and shook his
hand and um
asked what the issue was before the game
and he said there wasn't an issue
so i went to celebrate with my football
team
a lot of respect for john we shook hands
but again i i wanted to sprint down
there and be excited with the team and
then
sprinted back to midfield
a that's that he's a no-nonsense guy
listen and and you know he's he's a
really good person that's what i like
about mike he's a
you know he's just a normal guy that's
why you see him in practice hanging out
with the guys
and the guys really take to mike because
he's easy to talk to
he's been a player so he understands
what the players are going through
and i mean just think about he's young
and so he's still involved and he's
closer to the age of a lot of these
players
and it's pretty intense and malcolm
butler he's been their best player on
the defensive side of the ball
he's been intense he's been physical
he's competing at a high level you see
him out there tackling
he's done he's done a really great job
and i look at derek henry
the baltimore ravens did a tremendous
job
on derrick henry for about three and a
half quarters and all of a sudden in
that fourth quarter derrick henry just
absolutely took over
we saw his size and speed his
intimidation become a factor
in the game and that's what they do with
derrick can it doesn't really matter if
it's working or not work and they just
continue to hammer like
they will run into a front for zero
yards five times in a row
and not care they're fine with that
they'll just keep doing it and doing it
and doing it
and then eventually they'll break one
and then eventually throughout the
course of the game
even in the first half the ravens were
shutting down that running game
you know they're hitting tannehill they
even caused an interception based off
hitting tannehill
but in the second half they start to
supplement in the passing game and rod i
know
even going back to the miami days ryan
tannehill somebody you were really high
on what's the story
of his career so far in your eyes
well when he was in miami you you could
see the flashes of
of him being a good player he would play
well for a short period of time and
all of a sudden he'll get hurt then
they'll come back in and play and you
see the athleticism you see the movement
and then all of a sudden he'll get hurt
again but being in mike vrabo's system
because mike is a guy that understands
football he understands people he knows
how to relate to different people
and now he has the freedom he has a 250
pound back that he can hand it to
he's got tight ends he's got big
physical wide receivers and he's got a
good offensive line
that's missing a couple starters so um
when i look at mike brabo i think he's
he's really done a wonderful job of
really having those players come
together and that's what they are
they're a close-knit group they're smart
they're physical and they play well
under pressure
it reminds me a little bit of seattle a
year ago where it was like you know they
come out at the beginning of the game
and all they would do is run the
football run the football run the
football and then they'd get into the
second half and then you would see
russell wilson then they would start to
let russ cook
now the whole story this year has been
from the first quarter on they just want
to let rusko do his thing
is there any effect there when you watch
the titans play that they need to just
let tana hill go
sometimes because it always seems like
they sort of wait till the end and then
let him go do his thing where
is he good enough to just go take over a
game from the first quarter is that just
not what this
tennessee titans team's built to do no
we we've seen it we've seen it last year
and we've seen ryan take over but
he's not the quarterback where you want
him to do that every single week
you know as you want him to make sure
that he takes care of the ball
and hand it off to his 250-pound running
back i mean he doesn't have to take a
lot of chances but his
speed his athleticism really opens up um
things on the offensive side of the ball
because you're concerned from a
defensive standpoint about him running
you're concerned about these big wide
receivers you're also concerned about
john
smith who doesn't get enough credit
you're concerned about derrick henry so
you have so many things that you worry
about
but this team is not without flaws on
the defense side of the ball
we know they cannot get a pass rush to
save their lives
we talked last week do they add rashaan
evans as a fifth rusher
to create more pressure and then you
looking to back in on
the safeties haven't made any plays no
interceptions no sacks
and kevin bayer one of the best safeties
of national football they won the
highest paid safeties in the national
football league so
they need more production from their
safeties malcolm butler has been playing
outstanding this year
and then on the other side of the ball
lamar jackson they lost ronnie stanley
so it's been
mixing and mashing they're just moving
these offensive linemen
all around trying to figure out what
formula may be able to carry them home
but it's hard not to think obviously
clay as campbell's out too that's a big
loss for the defense but it's hard not
to think
is lamar good enough to win is he good
enough to take over and shoulder the
baltimore ravens
if he doesn't have the perfect
supporting cast because he came into the
league with really the perfect
supporting cast
the perfect run game great offensive
line really good defense
how do you see that though if it's not
perfect
is he able does he have the skill set to
be able to go win it all on his own
i don't think football is ever perfect
um but i would say
i don't believe he he can take over as a
passer
i just don't think he could take over a
game as a passer throw the ball 40 times
and have success and complete 70 and
take his team
when he was really at his best they were
able to run the football play action
pass
and they had a really good defense that
created a lot of turnovers got
good field position for the offense and
really set them up they were playing
good complimentary football
but what i've seen as of late the last
two weeks they've been physically
manhandled at the line of scrimmage and
the baltimore ravens
they won't have success unless they
control the line of scrimmage
well ronnie stanley was one of the best
pure pass blocking tackles in all of
football got paid like right before he
got hurt really a great run blocker too
but here is lamar jackson after the game
essentially saying that the rest of the
league wants the baltimore ravens to
lose hear this
let's focus keep our head up you know we
was in diverse situations in my rookie
year
and you know we turned the season around
people were down there then like i feel
like people want us to lose
but we just gotta bounce back we good
it's gonna be a rival game come thursday
and we turn up there
well that's just kind of fun yeah it's
not necessarily like people want to see
him lose people root for lamar
jackson because he's not the traditional
quarterback so there's
so maybe he's misconstruing things
there's a lot of support
i know i root for him i know you
probably root for him everybody
i mean people root for lamar because
he's a likable guy and he works
extremely hard
um but let's just see if he can use that
as motivation thursday because
they're going to need it against the
pittsburgh steelers
i'm right there with you okay so let's
keep it in the afc south
the colts they figure out some magical
way
to figure out a win they're down this is
one of those games that feels like with
21-7
nine times out of ten you think the
green bay packers pull this game off
but there's two fumbles down the stretch
the big one was on
the special teams the kickoff return
just perfectly set up the colts
and then marquez valdez scandaling
fumbles again and over time
back to back those are really
unpredictable plays that just killed
green bay down the stretch
but from the colts standpoint how did
you take this when finally knocking off
another heavyweight team
i thought it was huge for the colts
because when you start
beating really good teams then you start
to build confidence and that offensive
line was tremendous
phillip rivers is a statue as we know
one sack they gave up
one sack so he felt comfortable and and
he's
he's a stiff old man but at the end of
the day if you give him time and you
give him a nice clean pocket
he can pick you apart he can still sling
that thing but some individual
performances i want to talk about nahim
heinz
he's been their best offensive player
other than quentin nelson i mean he's
been absolutely phenomenal kind of
reminds me of old teammate
of mine kevin faulk run out catch out in
the backfield run in between the tackles
can do a little bit of everything but
you look at their tight end situation
trey byrd moali cox
jack doyle he came and scored a
touchdown he's been hurt
so they're doing a lot of positive
things on the offensive side and it's
not
one set receiver that they go to um zach
pascale
he's been great ty hill no longer has to
worry about being a number one receiver
because he's always hurt
he doesn't practice during the week so i
just think that philip rivers and his
experience and everything that he's
dealt with and that's the one thing that
everyone always talked about in
in in la when he played with the
chargers is
if you give philip rivers some time that
he can be able to make you pay
and and that's what he's doing with the
coach right now
well let's hear from phillip rivers
after the game because this really was a
big win and we mentioned you know the
mishaps on the part of
and really even aaron rodgers after a
game like this aaron riders typically
look so
ticked off that it's like he can't even
you know pretend to smile he was like on
the field
going back and forth kind of joking
around with phillip rivers i think the
reason is
a-rod really played a perfect game too
and would have had
multiple chances to go win it a on the
drive if they don't fumble the kickoff
he would have a chance right there
and then again on the valdez scantling
drive as well so let's hear from philip
rivers after a big win
offensively from an offensive standpoint
you're going gosh we shouldn't be in
this situation we got to finish it we
can't put our defense in this mode but
yeah so you certainly have those
thoughts but at the same time you're uh
you're fired up i mean you're believing
that the defense is going to get a stop
and they did and yes did they go 80
yards and get a field goal they did but
they didn't end the game
and they kept us alive and then they
went out there and got the takeaway
so that's a top five scoring defense
there in indy one of the best offensive
lines in football they traded up to go
get jonathan taylor in the draft and i
think
there's certain moments in the game
where you see why they wanted to go get
taylor in the second round i believe
that it was
andy the colts are you a believer is
this a team that can make a deep run and
go win a super bowl or is this a little
bit of fool's gold here
i i don't i mean you're asking me in
week 11 if they can go and win a super
bowl i mean they're they're playing
better now and and i'm gonna tell you
their special teams have really been key
for them especially teams
whether it was stopping cordero
patterson whether it's a block punt
and they score against the tennessee
titan whatever it is
they they they step up and they make
plays
so you're asking me is that will the
coach go to the super bowl i would say
no because they have the kansas city
chiefs and the pittsburgh steelers
but to me when i watched that game i saw
a lot i saw
from a defensive standpoint i saw
offensively them spreading the ball
around
jonathan taylor really stood out because
the last couple weeks
his number of reps kind of dropped so
they gave him an
opportunity and they kind of had that
naheen heinz and jonathan taylor going
on and that's what they need they need
that big physical back
that can get those tough yards and
that's exactly what jonathan taylor did
i was really impressed when we played
his best game of the year
and there were two other great
quarterbacks also that got together in
prime time last night when we got to see
the raiders we got to see the chiefs go
at it
and it felt to me like this was a game
where
carr derek carr sort of elevated himself
from one of those
middle of the pack quarterbacks that we
can't quite tell if he's going to be low
or going to be high and
to some degree we have to step back and
just give the full story of what
happened with the raiders because their
car really had to go
with the franchise i mean it was a full
rebuild amari cooper gets traded cleo
mac gets traded
they just load up on draft picks they're
gonna go do it in the draft they're
gonna go pay
young talent and it's what they've done
and now he's really circled around with
the roster
they have players they have talent
around them and he's starting to look
like he may be one of these top-tier
quarterbacks
even in a loss to the best team in
football in the kansas city chiefs
yeah i said it last night i felt like he
you know john gruden came in and did a
wonderful job with
derek carr you know before he came in he
was very conservative
he was an average quarterback he didn't
have a lot of talent around him
now you look and he's a top 10
quarterback he's playing extremely well
he's not turning the ball over
and the one thing that he talked about
this offseason is gaining respect i want
respect well the way you go out and get
respect is you have to go out and you
have to play well on the national stage
and that's exactly what he's been able
to do and you look at
him standing toe to toe with patrick my
homes and not being afraid
using his weapons and the confidence
that john gruden has given him has
really elevated and taken him to the
next level
you know because i was that guy the last
few years saying man
car is terrible i used to call him check
down charlie because i expected nothing
over 10
15 yards and now all of a sudden it's
this new car
he's he's playing with a lot more
confidence and you hear him when he's at
the line of scrimmage
calling out checks adjustments hey 50 50
is the mic
just doing everything he's supposed to
do and i just i just love
the the confidence that he's playing
with right now
that that was one of the coolest parts
about watching last night's game it's
like one of the most memorable there's
been so many good sunday night football
games this year
that was one of the most memorable games
and i think the reason why i was like we
really leaned in on the on-field sound
and hearing car
and as impressive as he was and has been
playing this year specifically against
the chiefs
talking about carr it was even more
impressive to watch the way that he
leads the offense
leads this group of men he's like so
confident up there like throws you back
to
you know payton or brady or somebody
like that like he views himself in that
same light
and he's almost even a little cocky
about it like calling out defenders and
doing stuff like that
to me that's where you get belief and
like the the criticism
of car over the last couple of years i
get it it's part of it you hire a new
coach it's fancy like groon comes in
quarterback whisper whatever you want to
say like people wanted it to work right
away
but they brought in mayok they let
gruden really run the show like most
head coaches don't get him to do
from a gm standpoint and they just
dismantled this entire roster
it was just dismantled and so i just
think we had to wait on it and now you
have josh jacobs and darren waller
starting to look like he may be one or
two or three i think he's in the top
three like george kettle
kelsey waller those three are all in one
grouping at the top of the league right
now he looks so fast playing the tight
end position
and nobody wants to cover hey man you're
just like a typical fan
all you do is focus on all the offensive
players josh jacobs darren waller all
these different guys
what about the defense show the defense
some love and those guys listen
those guys they're not great but i do
believe that mayok
and john gruden they're maybe one or two
drafts away from being exactly where
they want to be they still have to find
max crosby is a really good player
but they don't have that stud that stud
pass rusher
and they're trying to find out their
linebacker situation i like the guys in
the secondary they compete those corners
they compete
and and jonathan abram he's a missile
he's a firecracker
so if they can control him and just
continue to build
through the draft you know in the next
couple years if
carr continues to play the way he's
played i would say the raiders
definitely have a chance
to be competitive just like they are now
against kansas city chiefs
yeah it'd be so nice if they had one of
those just all time you know bookend
you know just great pass rushers like
khalil mack right that could be it'd be
just so sweet if they could just have
one of those guys
they had them they traded them away like
that that was just but you know what
entire strategy when they're built in
this team
yeah go ahead yeah and at
that time we all thought that was crazy
we were like how do you get rid of
khalil mack
and khalil he played well he came in and
made a huge splash
then the second year um kind of went
down a little bit now people are
questioning is this the same khalil mack
this that and the other
and john gru knew exactly we're not
we're on a bad team
so it doesn't matter if he brings 15
sacks but we're not going to pay this
guy 22 million
a year when we're trying to tear up
everything and completely rebuild
john gruden felt like he had the
quarterback he wanted he drafted the
running back
signed darren waller to a long-term
contract already had the offensive line
set up um trent brown brought him
in from the patriots and made some other
moves but defensively
if they want to go to the next level
because they got us they gotta face
patrick my homes the next 15
20 years think about it this guy doesn't
get touched he doesn't get hit
so you know he's going to play 20 years
he's going to be he
see these young guys they look at brady
they look at brees they look at all
these guys that have
long tenured careers and they're saying
look we're a lot more athletic than them
the technology and all the supplements
and things that we can do
heck if i don't have a major injury i
could play for the next 15 20 years and
that's the way patrick mahomes is
looking at it well he can throw the ball
at least like tom brady
probably better than tom brady talking
about homes i mean his arm angles and
the way he can lean his body back left
and back foot and still put everything
into a ball
i mean just think about that play to go
win it at the end of the game rodney
when he's
he's scrambling to the right he draws
that safety off of travis kelsey like
think about how scared you have to be
of patrick mahomes running in that
touchdown to
come off of travis kelsey in coverage to
come off of them and like and that's
what we're seeing with this next level
of quarterback play is that they're such
dynamic runners
that you have to treat them like mike
vick or something like oh he's gonna go
score a touchdown if i don't come up
but the only difference is when he drops
back and throws it just like we're
saying he's a better passer than tom
brady i don't know how you defend that
and so far nor does the rest of the nfl
because they can't stop patrick mahomes
then you put these weapons and you put
andy reed with it and it literally is
unstoppable just like it was last night
absolutely and you know as a fan i sit
back and i just watch and i shake my
head and
you know you go back to some of your old
defenses and i say you know what that my
2003 defense
how would we play this guy you know we
had some pass rushers we had a couple
guys that could spot a quarterback
we had some guys that could take care of
the deep end of the secondary
but you sit back and you say this guy is
absolutely amazing it's like the most
incredible thing like
vic blew me away michael vick blew me
away when i saw him
run and some of the things that he could
do on the football field
but this patrick mahomes if how humble
he is his work ethic
and everything that they've done to
surround him with a
a crazy tough offensive line and that's
the one thing i want to emphasize
and no one talks about their offensive
line everyone talks about all their
weapons
their offensive line is nasty dirty
physical
and that's why they have so much success
running the ball that's why they have so
much great protection
it comes down to this offensive line we
know what patrick mahomes can do
it is and the chiefs defense will stink
stink stink stink stink
but then they'll have moments where
they're great for short periods of time
like they were last year on the super
bowl run
and that's how they go win super bowl so
i think that that could still be
in the formula as we speak at the top of
the afc let's get to the pittsburgh
steelers so they dominate
the jacksonville jaguars but there's
something to
playing your best when competition
lowers what's your biggest takeaway
watching the steelers get to 10 wins the
only unbeaten team in football
to me it was it has to start with the
head coach mike tomlin came out early
this week and he talked about hey
we're not disrespecting the jaguars we
understand who we're playing we
understand that we won
x amount of games but this is a
legitimate team they took green bay and
gave green bay
fits so the the focus level of this team
is because of their head coach but the
maturity of the players
on this team to understand that they
just can't go out there and expect to
win
they have to put some work in and i i
just tell you this man the one thing
that i saw
jack that i really appreciate bring me
back to jack so i can see him please
the one thing i like ab what i
absolutely love about the pittsburgh
steelers
okay and that little photo that they
showed all these guys are very talented
guys and every week
it's a different wide receiver making
plays but if you notice one thing about
them
they all celebrate each other's success
and i just
absolutely love that because i'm such a
team guy and when you see that when you
see a guy
catching a touchdown and you run 30 40
yards and you give them a hug and you
celebrate
that builds team trust camaraderie all
those different things
and that's what i love about the
pittsburgh still is mike thomas done a
great job of getting rid of some of that
old stuff throwing away the bad people
and guess what bringing in good quality
young football players
that work well and you know ben
roethlisberger his attitude is
completely different if you notice
he's a lot more humble he seems like
he's gone through some things that
forced him to grow up
and he's just a different man
and it's such great points i just love
everything you just said but not only to
go out and find
you know he's found great talent too not
only good people like not only team
first guys like he had to replace the
killer
bees we're talking about ab le'veon bell
martavis bryant like they had so many
great players
on that team at one point in time and so
it's like okay personalities are not
mixing and meshing so well with ben
roethlisberger that's not good
i just wonder too like did ben learn
some lessons did ben
change his approach to the way he goes
about some of his stuff too i'm gonna
guess he probably did
he's having one of the best years of his
career i think this is gonna go down
best weapons yes but best years for big
ben 2 on pace for one of his highest
ever touchdown totals
lowest interception totals one of his
highest completion percentages one of
his highest passing yard seasons
they're 10-0 a better record than the
kansas city chiefs who we just got done
drooling over
i mean this and then you start talking
about their defense
uh and what their defense is able to do
and why fitzpatrick i mean they just
have so many great players
uh and i think mike tomlin deserves all
the credit in the world for not only
humbling
but bringing in that same caliber of
talent that can go compete for
championships
and this this show is called the safety
blitz and now that we're
we're talking about the pittsburgh
steelers their safeties were outstanding
last well yesterday absolutely
outstanding four interceptions mika
fitzpat
patrick and terrell edmonds four
interceptions
imagine and and i was i was very blessed
to be able to play
behind great pass rushers and willie
mcginnis mike frapon those guys and
richard seymour
but think about bud dupree and these
guys and
tj watt tj watt i think he's defensive
player of the year
i don't know what his sack total is but
every time i look up he's in the
backfield causing havoc
i think he's the defensive player of the
year right now but i like what mike
thomas doing give him a lot of credit
right now mike tomlin
um coach of the year right now
i'm with you it's just going to come
down to which of those two teams can
score more points against each other
and or which of those two teams can get
a stop and as it currently sits i think
the team more likely to get a stop now i
understand they're going up against
you know mahomes and the chiefs but that
steelers defense just looks considerably
better
than what we're seeing defensively in
kansas city okay so as we see this
ascension of the pittsburgh steelers in
the afc
that means one team must fall that team
is your former team
in the new england patriots they keep
kind of coming back down
to reality after an unexpectedly great
start
what did you see yesterday i was just
really disappointed because
i'm i thought the game plan that we saw
against the ravens
i thought that was going to be pretty
similar to what we saw against the
houston texans
and of course josh mcdaniel's offense
coordinator i love no death but
i think he blew it i mean cam had 365
yards passing
i think he passed 40 sometimes that's
not a formula for cam newton
it's just not you look over the course
of his career when he's thrown 40 plus
times
majority of the time he's loses those
games so when i
look i just didn't like the game planet
that was on the offensive side of the
ball
and you look and then also damien harris
he only carried the ball 11 times
against the ravens he had 22 carries and
i think 121 yards
so it's like what what are you trying to
prove what are you trying to do
just stick to what you do best and
and think about this jack the houston
texans had the worst
run defense in a national football
league the worse
but you completely change up your game
plan
and you want to pass the ball 40 plus
times with cam newton why
and even even with cam throwing the ball
pretty well you just look at the outside
and i i've always kind of felt this way
about cam newton i don't think he's ever
had great wide receivers and again he
just has
bad wide receivers and then you subtract
julian edelman from that group
and not only bad wide receivers no tight
end really to speak of either
here was cam newton fairly or unfairly
it's just part of the nature of being on
a short-term deal
on his future in new england
i don't know if you've had a chance to
think about it yet but do you
do you have interest in being a patriot
in 2021
man i had interest in winning
the arizona cardinals game how about
that
i mean there's so many things that
that i mean i i don't want to even
harp or dwell or even think i think my
my
as the bible says my covet runneth over
us
you know with just trying to focus on
you know the near future rather than the
far future
and jack who does that sound like that
is let me tell you something
because that's not the cam newton that
we saw after the super bowl the one that
had an attitude the one that didn't
answer question the one act like a
crybaby
that's a grown man right there and i
tell you when you go through tough times
and you lose your job you get hurt and
nobody wants you
it's a humbling experience but this is
one of the best things
that happened to cam newton because
regardless of how the season goes he's
always going to remember
all the lessons that bill belichick
taught him and
the fact that he's not thinking about
2021 he's
looking at the arizona cardinals that's
that's the key with bill belichick he
makes sure that
everyone that's in that locker room
focuses on
the next week and not worrying about
everything else that's that's why i love
coach belichick because he has that that
weird
ability to keep all his guys so focused
on the job at hand
he does and it's the reason why so many
players where you know
maybe it wouldn't work out with this
team or that team or this team or that
team
it seems to work out in new england
while this hasn't exactly panned out
perfectly yet there's no question that
you've seen
maturity in cam newton and there's also
no question that you've seen the reason
why tom brady left
right i just think that there's no doubt
when you when you look outside you go
okay so they're asking cam newton to
throw the ball now you know this many
times per game
and that's who he's throwing the ball to
his best receiver is an undrafted free
agent
that he played with from 2015 to 2018 in
carolina and bert that's
that's his best receiver and then behind
him you're like
man what what else do you want him to do
here which is why i go back to your
point
run the ball with them or you know come
up with a new strategy or a new draft
pick or something
because these guys just aren't that open
yeah and you think about their playoff
chances and
to me that was a must win because when
you look at their schedule
they still have to face miami they got
to play the rams
they got to play arizona they got to
play buffalo
like those are tough games those are
going to be a lot more tough games than
say the houston texas with the worst
rush run defense in all of football so
when i'm looking at the patriots i'm
like okay you still got to play hard
and then you look kind of on the
defensive side of the ball the mccordy
brothers haven't really played
as well as they should should have you
know the wood as well as they should
have played this year i
it hurts my heart but it's over for the
patriots
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports